♪ ♪
>> Kaite: PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A HUGE
POLITICAL PROBLEM ON THEIR
HANDS, VICE PRESIDENT, HARRIS
AND THE BP POLL NUMBERS ARE
DROPPING LIKE A ROCK AND THERE
IS CONCERN THAT HARRIS COULD
DOOM DEMOCRATS INTO THE
MIDTERMS.
TO BE IT'S BECAUSE OF LIKE
THESE.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO VISIT THE
BORDER?
>> NOT TODAY.
[LAUGHS]
>> WE'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVE BEEN TO EUROPE.
>> YOU WILL HAVE TUESDAY ROCKS
OR PHOTOCOPIER I.D.
IT THERE ARE PEOPLE LIVE IN THE
WORLD COMMUNITY, THERE'S NO
KINKO'S OR OFFICEMAX.
>> Kaite: THEY THINK IT WILL
BE REALLY GOOD FOR THEM.
>> ANYBODY IN A REAL SWING
DISTRICT, THEY ARE NOT SENDING
HER.
SHE'S UNDERWATER IN THE REAL
CLEAR POLITICS AVERAGE AND THAT
IS HARD TO DO AS A DEMOCRAT.
I LOOKED AT THE TREND LINE AND
IT REALLY STARTED TO DIP ONCE A
JOKE PUT HER -- WHY ARE YOU
LAUGHING?
AND YOU KNOW RIGGED POLLS,
RICHARD.
THE DEMOCRATS KNEW SHE FLAKED.
REMEMBER WHEN JOE TAPPED HER?
SHE DIDN'T EVEN GET A BUMP.
THEN WHEN SHE DEBATED PENS, HE
MOPPED THE FLOOR WITH HER.
IF IT WASN'T FOR THE FLY ON HIS
HEAD IT WOULD'VE BEEN A PERFECT
GAME.
THE REST IS CACKLING AND DODGING
AND THOUGH SHE IS JEALOUS OF
JILL BECAUSE JILL IS GETTING
GOOD PRESS.
THE VP IS A HUGE ASSET.
SHE'S YOUNG AND SHE CAN TRAVEL
AND HER SCHEDULES MORE FLEXIBLE.
YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO DEPLOY HER
WHERE YOU WANT TO DEPLOY HER
BECAUSE IT COULD BACKFIRE AND
THAT KIND OF GOES TO JUMP.
IT TELLS YOU WHO JOE IS AS A
POLITICIAN TO PICK SOMEONE NOT
BAD AS YOUR NUMBER ONE.
>> ONE WAS THE LAST TIME YOU DID
A WHOLE SEGMENT ABOUT MIKE PENCE
OR DICK CHENEY?
OR GEORGE W. BUSH?
I MEAN -- I AM SPEAKING.
I'M SPEAKING.
MY POINT HERE IS, I THINK THE
REASON WHY SHE'S GETTING AT THAT
IS BECAUSE SHE IS THE FIRST
WOMAN TO TAKE A CASE.
>> YOU ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
YOU ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
>> AND THE MEDIA WAS SO NICE TO
SARAH PALIN.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO MIX APPLES
AND ORANGES, I'LL CALL A SPADE A
SPADE.
>> Greg: AND SO, SO IT'S -- >>
BOTH WHEN THEY WERE CANDIDATES
AND OTHER SHE'S A
VICE PRESIDENT.
I THINK ALSO IT'S VERY EARLY IN
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S TERM, SHE
HAD ONE ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
YET, AND WHAT SHE HAS BEEN DOING
IS RAISING MONEY FOR THE PARTIES
AND DOING THAT VERY EFFECTIVELY
SO SHE'S DOING PART OF HER JOB
EFFECTIVELY AND WE HAVE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK JOE
PICKED HER, THAT'S THE FIRST
PART.
THE DEMS THOUGHT THEY ACTUALLY
DRAFTED CAPABLE QUARTERBACK IN
HER BUT THEY GOT AN ERRATIC
PLACE KICKER WHO WITH ALMOST ALL
THE KICKS.
AND SHE'S NOT INTO IT, SHE
DOESN'T LIKE IT.
SHE'S GOT NERVOUS LAUGHTER AND
THE EXHAUSTION.
I WAS A TECH WRITER AND IT WAS
SO OVER MY HEAD, TALKING IN
VAGARIES AND GENERALITIES,
EXACTLY WHAT SHE DID.
I THOUGHT HER FLAWS COULD BE
REMEDIED BUT ALWAYS GIVE THE
IMPRESSION THAT SHE WAS A LIGHT
WEIGHT AND WITH THE WRONG PERSON
FOR THE WRONG JOB BUT IT HASN'T
CHANGED.
WHAT MADE IT WORSE WAS EVEN THE
ROOT CAUSE TERM PAPER THAT THEY
ASSIGNED HER.
IT FELT LIKE IT WAS AN
ASSIGNMENT THAT I DID IN GRADE
SCHOOL FOR YOU...
S GRANT AND EVERYTHING THAT WAS
IN HER THING COULD HAVE BEEN
COBBLED TOGETHER FROM WIKIPEDIA.
SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY GO
THERE, NOTHING IN THAT MAKEWORK
PAPER ASSIGNED TO HER CAME
ACROSS AS ANYTHING OR FRESH.
IT WAS JUST KIND OF
EMBARRASSING.
I THINK THEY WILL HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION SOON.
THE UPSIDE IS, SHE'S CREATED A
BAR SOLO THAT ANYTIME SHE DOES
SOMETHING HALFWAY DECENT, IT
WILL BE CONSIDERED A SUCCESS IN
THE MEDIA.
THEY WANT TO ROOT FOR HER.
NO ONE IS BEING SEXIST TOWARDS
HER.
THEY WANT HER TO SUCCEED.
SO IT'S SOMETHING TINY THAT'S
RIGHT.
IT WILL BE ALL OVER.
>> Kaite: WOMEN AREN'T SO FOND
OF THE VICE PRESIDENT REGARDLESS
OF POLITICAL PARTY.
>> Shannon: DURING THE
CAMPAIGN WE GOT A MEMO THAT CAME
UP FROM A LARGE NUMBER OF
WOMEN'S GROUPS THAT SAID, WE ARE
WATCHING YOU.
DO YOU GUYS ARE A MEMBER THAT
MEMO?
AT SEVERAL PAGES LONG.
LARGE GROUPS OF WOMEN
REPRESENTING WOMEN BUT THEY SAID
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT HER BECAUSE
IF YOU DO IT'S GOING TO BE
SEXIST AND SHE'S GOING TO BE
MAD.
SHE DROPPED OUT OF THE PRIMARIES
AND SINGLE DIGITS, BUT IT WASN'T
LIKE THERE WAS OVERWHELMING
THIRST FOR HER DURING THE
PRIMARIES AND SHE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO CONNECT.
THEY ARE GIVING HER SOME OF THE
TOUGHEST ASSIGNMENTS AND THERE'S
GRUMBLING AMONG WASHINGTON AND
HER STAFF, LIKE SHE'S GETTING
THE ASSIGNMENT.
>> Greg: LIKES TO GET THE
SINGLE DIGITS WERE STAFF.
>> Richard: I'M PROUD TO SEE
KAMALA HARRIS THERE AND I WANT
HER TO DO THE BEST J